nos ponen aquí el siguiente ejercicio
dice considera la gráfica de f y aquí
tienen ustedes esta curva azul que es
justo la gráfica de nuestra función
fx y nos dan varios puntos a b c d e f y
nos dice en qué puntos de la gráfica es
este límite límite cuando h tiende a
cero de fx + h - f x / h igual a cero
esa es nuestra primer pregunta y vamos a
tratar de resolverla nos dicen cuando el
límite cuando h tiende a cero de fx + h
- efe de x / h es igual a 0 bien cuando
ocurre esto y recordemos simplemente que
esto es la definición de la derivada
verdad la definición de la derivada es
si nosotros tomamos algún punto digamos
este ok y nos tomamos un x + h digamos
uno por aquí entonces fx más h
fx es esta altura verdad es esta altura
esto es f x + h - f x muy bien y h
simplemente es lo que nos desplazamos
hacia acá entonces esencialmente esto es
la proporción entre la altura y la base
de este triángulo lo que lo que
incrementamos o bajamos en ye y lo que
aumentamos en x verdad dividido entre lo
que aumentamos en x y nos dice bueno
después hace el límite cuando h tiende a
cero es decir removiendo este punto
hacia o vamos tendiendo hacia este punto
de aquí y esencialmente eso nos da la la
pendiente de la recta tangente muy bien
entonces lo que nos dice es cuando la
derivada es cero
y hay que ver en estos puntos por
ejemplo aquí en el punto a nuestra
derivada o más bien la pendiente de la
recta tangente pues es negativa verdad
la la línea va hacia abajo en b en b
aquí sí parece que la derivada de 0 aquí
parece que la derivada de cero porque
eso significaría que la recta es
horizontal a diferencia por ejemplo de
lo que pasa con sé que ahora la recta
tangente sería positiva perdón la
pendiente de la recta tangente sería
positiva lo mismo ocurre con d
lo mismo ocurre con d aunque ya es menos
pronunciada que ence y otra vez en en
que vuelve a ser negativa la pendiente
muy bien lo mismo pasará con efe es
negativa así que cuando la derivada de 0
cuando este límite cero pues sólo hay un
caso verdad y que es en el caso de ve
muy bien ahora vamos a ver qué pasa con
la segunda pregunta queremos ver cuándo
efe de x por su derivada en ese mismo
punto es menor que cero
entonces fíjense que para que una
multiplicación de dos números sea menor
que cero uno tiene que ser positivo y el
otro tiene que ser negativo muy bien
puede que esté sea positivo y esté
negativo o puede que esté sea negativo y
esté positivo sin embargo vamos a checar
algo en todos estos puntos en a b
d e y f todos esos se encuentran por
arriba del eje x quiere decir que en
todos estos lugares la función es
positiva así que aquí fx es positiva así
que lo único que tenemos que ver es
cuando la derivada es negativa muy bien
entonces la derivada es negativa por
ejemplo en a
y también es negativa en el i ene efe
muy bien aquí justamente la recta
tangente va como hacia abajo verdad va
hacia abajo y entonces ahí la derivada
es negativa entonces cuáles son
y efe
muy bien así que ya tenemos la respuesta
a este problema